[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
émission donne envie de lecture
aujourd'hui autour de la table nous
avons quatre invités que je vais laisser
je vais vous laisser vous présentez un
par un gabriel de prochaine bonjour
bonjour moi je suis gâté de vos chaînes
je suis auteur d'un roman qui est sorti
il ya six mois il s'appelle je voudrais
disposition tekki parfait le genre
carton bonjour votre pseudo c'est géraud
n'at-on et vous êtes ici pour
représenter le 2 tome 2 de votre nouvel
album qui vient de sortir au début puis
à peu près 60 ans et ma spécialité c'est
l'histoire mais surtout les innovations
précolombienne alors j'ai sorti rassam a
le tome 2 e ligne du soir vrai qui se
passait à l'époque des banques us à la
parfait jacques fournit déjà un habitué
de l'émission oui bonjour qu'est ce que
de quoi aller nous voulons parler
aujourd'hui
le cert responsable des itinéraires
politique à saint quentin en yvelines
mais on peut parler d'autre chose que de
poésie aussi j'ai parlé de dans la forêt
de de djenné glande d'un roman américain
paru aux éditions gallmeister
dans cette très belle maison d'édition
de romans américains et c'est un livre
de survie très bien mais est notre
dernier invité ophélie félix bonjour
vous avez un coup de coeur
alors moi j'ai chargé des arts visuels
aussi pour l'agglomération de saint
quentin à la direction de la culture et
je ne pars pas par visual aujourd'hui
mais d'un roman que j'ai dû cet été
qu'ils s'appellent fugitif parce que
rennes c'est sur les rapports mère-fille
eh bien eh bien je vous écoute qu'est ce
qui vous a fasciné dans ce roman
alors qu'est-ce qui m'a fasciné dans ce
roman j'ai trouvé que c'est un
magnifique roman pourquoi parce que
cette mère elle est un peu déglingué et
en même temps c'est hyper beau cette
histoire tout ses fêlures font
finalement la force de ses filles
c'est assez profond alors c'est parfois
un peu un peu trash parce que cet amour
il est passionnel donc il est plein
d'excès l'amour qu'elle a pour ses
filles est plein d'excès mais aussi son
amour de l'alcool de enfin et c'est
vraiment autobiographique c'est un roman
autobiographique qui est vraiment très
bien écrit donc c'est violer nuit sman
c'est très bien écrit alors elle écrit à
la première personne mais souvent à
l'emploi le nous parce que elle a une
relation très
et aussi très passionnelle avec sa soeur
dont elle parle en leur nom et du coup
j'ai cru que c'était à la fois une très
jolie histoire ce relation mère fille et
leur relation entre soeurs et donc gg
être sélectionné quelques lignes
j'aimerais vous lire parce que je trouve
que c'est au début du livre et ça donne
la teneur globale du roman jetterait que
c'était plus simple que ça parle mieux
que moi alors cet amour fou cette
passion intenable que représentait de
moutarde avec leur emmerdements à tout
âge cet amour qui n'en finissait pas qui
ne pouvait pas finir qui survivaient à
tout semblait plus haut que tout
pardonner tout cet amour qui la faisait
nous appeler quand nous n'étions pas des
petites comme des ou des
pétasses mecheri adoré que j'aime à la
folie cet amour la vie vivre autant
qu'elle le plus voilà donc je trouve que
ça donne la teneur du roman souffre de
maniaco-dépression alors oui c'est ça
elle passe elle est très passionné et
donc elle passe par des phases où elle
est complètement voilà lé cyclothymique
est complètement exalté et d'autres
façons elle est complètement dépressive
et ses filles la suivre dans cette danse
infinie se soutiennent la soutiennent et
c'est vraiment magnifique c'est vraiment
magique ce livre ça j'ai eu cet été ont
fait pas deux trois jours je vais
commencer je n'ai pas
je n'ai pas fermé quoi j'ai cependant
bien c'est un premier roman aux éditions
gallimard qui a reçu le prix du roman
marie claire 2018 voilà merci ophélie
découverte
c'est une bonne transition avec votre
livre jacques puisque c'est aussi
l'histoire de deux soeurs
oui mais ya pas de mère a disparu
c'est l'histoire de deux soeurs n'est
leva qui vivent dans une maison isolée
par la volonté familiale en bordure
d'une forêt et
on ne sait pas pourquoi mais le monde
autour s'écroule complètement la
civilisation disparaît complètement et
donc se retrouve seul et donc c'est un
livre de survie puisqu'il faut survivre
il faut continuer à vivre malgré tout
quand on a 16 et 17 ans ou 17 et 18 ça
se passe sur plusieurs années et c'est
un livre qui a été publiée il ya une
vingtaine d'années aux états unis qui a
eu un succès phénoménal qui a été adapté
au cinéma il ya 4 16 par une cinéaste
canadienne oui patricia rozema voilà qui
ne font pas un film français qui porte
le même titre qui est sorti l'an dernier
d'influents un roman fantastique un film
fantastique et donc là on est sur une
édition très récent puisque le livre est
sorti en 2010 est aux éditions
gallmeister
et c'est un livre d'une dune grande de
salive d'initiation tout simple on va
dire la verdure vie la suite de la
serrure grâce grâce à soi même aussi
grâce à ce que peut apporter
l'environnement proche même si on ne le
connaît pas et qu'on apprend que le
personnage de neil est une grande
lectrice de l'encyclopédie donc elle
découvre tout à travers la lecture des
articles
des choses qui valent à qui vont très
loin dans le roman je peux pas tout
dévoiler parce qu'il ya des scènes assez
c'est magnifique dedans et la forêt
point c'est le lieu de refuge et le lieu
à la fois d'alimentation de peur de
refuge ce qui est systématiquement la
forêt voilà et donc ce livre là est un
livre sur justement comment nos pas
comment on peut survivre pour survie
mais comment en plus l'humanité se
recrée à travers ces deux femmes
ses deux filles qui deviennent femmes
elles seules entre l on va dire sans
avec très peu d'apports extérieurs
parfait au col du beal prendra part
c'est que c'est le canada qui s'en est
emparé mais c'est canada parce que ça se
passe d'ailleurs en bordure de dans une
journée en bordure de la frontière
canadienne
on est on est complètement dans les
forêts du nord north american et donc
c'est un film qui voilà que très très
peu de succès très mal distribués mais
le livre est à lire absolument parfait
merci beaucoup dans prix jacques et nous
on passe à un tout autre univers qu'est
celui de la bande dessinée de l'empiré
maya et et de la découverte
une forme de découverte des terres
nouvelles qui précède les conquistadors
de quelques années votre personnage donc
j'ai eu envie de raconter
vie d'un conquistador qui avaient ce
naufrage chez les mayas et qui a par la
suite posé de gros problèmes aux autres
qu'on krisada parce qu'il est devenu le
maïs est complètement adapté et il a
combattu les espagnols alors c'était
intéressant pour deux raisons parce que
il n'est pas du tout connu en europe ou
très peu un peu plus au mexique où il
des statuts de lui derrière et mais il
n'y a pas de vraie biographie de lui
alors on peut raconter sa vie même dans
dans les plus petits détails parce que
tous les cocus jada qui sont arrivés par
la suite conduit à faire à ce type
contre l'un de ceux ci le dit cela et
puis on arrive à faire une image j'ai
rien inventé ou et marmites
il est parti d'une vraie histoire et
puis la brader nos noms j'ai raconté
tout ce qu'on sait de lui voilà et c'est
l'endroit culture maya en arrivant et
ses huit enfants
cortes cortese avant tout le monde quand
il faut résister un petit groupe il ya
tout tout une partie qui sont fait sa
crise et
il a été plus malin que les autres il
s'est vraiment adapté et il a aussi
prévenu qu'il a sauvée parce que gmail
ont été les premiers et contacté par les
conquistadors dans l'est dans les
grandes civilisations et ils ont été les
derniers à être vaincu parce qu'en fait
il les a prévenus
il a dit je le rappelle est d'égaler
leur disparition le nom apparaît à la
rencontre et grâce à ça il est mort
d'ailleurs un combattant des espagnols
les maillons résister plus que tous les
autres alors que ce type à un peuple
spécialement guerrier voilà et on
aperçoit donc sur les écrans des
planches des couverture du tome 2 qui
vient de sortir
c'est un dessin très très academy à
d'état qui est très poussé qu'un très
poussée je veux pas toujours ce genre là
mais c'est ici charge d'un mais beaucoup
de ça fait des années que je voulais
raconter mais je me sentais pas prêt
donc j'ai tout c'est très fort et les
graphismes
très bien merci beaucoup pour cet
c'est une belle ouvrage est notre
dernière invitée gabriel beauchesne vous
venez nous parler d'un livre d'un coup
de coeur
un coup de coeur récents alors je vous
parlais de livres que j'ai écrits donc
en fait moi je suis j'ai vécu en multi
nuitées opérationnel militaire pendant
une quinzaine d'années et j'ai eu
l'occasion de visiter de nombreux pays
et c'est vrai que j'ai fait beaucoup de
formation pour les jeunes les jeunes
officiers donc de quinzaine de nations
différentes et notamment des pays en
guerre et je me suis aperçu d'une chose
c'est que tous ces jeunes étaient
brutalement en quête de sens et c'est
aussi pour ça quand on a vu arriver dans
le terrorisme qui sait importer en
france parce que ce type de procédé là
quand on imitait on le connaît dans les
pays étrangers mais quand c'est venu se
sait importer en france
je me suis dit il ya quand même quelque
chose à faire pour ces jeunes qui sont
prêts à aller jusque là
comment ça se fait que dans notre
société on puisse avoir des jeunes qui
sont pour la plupart mes compatriotes
nos compatriotes puissent faire ce genre
de choses et donc c'est parti un peu de
là où j'ai écrit ce roman qui
raconte l'histoire d'un jeune homme
brendon qui a été embrigadé dans un
réseau terroriste qui a préparé un acte
terroriste et c'est comme ça commence le
roman dans ce premier chapitre où il est
avec ses explosifs à la ceinture dans
son train et il doit faire sauter ses
explosifs
il se passe quelque chose dans ce
premier chapitre où il rencontre en fait
un jeune garçon qui est lu par un
certain nombre de choses mais c'est pas
tellement ce que lui dit le garçon qui
va le toucher c'est le regard que ce
garçon a sur ce jeune homme
et là il se dit il notamment ce regard
de liberté c'est à dire que ça vous est
peut-être arrivé parce tous beaucoup de
temps région parisienne dans les
transports en commun d'être dans le rer
d'avoir quelqu'un qui rentre et qui vous
fait peur donc ça arrive souvent
et là c'est un petit peu ça c'est
brandon qui est là il fait peur aux gens
mais ce garçon il n'a pas peur de lui et
du coup il se passe quelque chose et
brendan se dit mais ce garçon là me
parle en liberté ce que moi je suis en
liberté est donc bon je vous révèle qu'à
la fin du chapitre il fera pas sauter sa
charge et tout le roman c'est la
construction de la quête de sa vie dira
qu' il va essayer de chercher ce qui a
liberté est ce que l'homme peut être
libre et donc y rencontrer divers
rencontres tout au long de son
itinéraire
alors c'est écrit sous la forme d'un
thriller donc c'est très rythmé
parce que évidemment comme il a renoncé
à son acte l'état leur recherche le déan
doctrine mais voilà qu'en fait lui c'est
la reconstruction
voilà ce n'est pas propre identité et
donc l'état le recherche mais également
donc ses anciens amis et donc qu'ils
rencontrent nibas personnes notamment
donc une fille avec qui elle va essayer
de le
de lui enseigner un certain nombre de
choses et puis va construire un petit
peu comme ça son itinéraire pour savoir
si l'homme peut être libre donc c'est un
livre sur la liberté c'est un livre
aussi qui voit là me parle de cette
liberté en se demandant si vraiment la
liberté c'est un choix radical soit dans
une rame une subjectivité radical un peu
la sartre ou alors c'est plutôt la
recherche d'une réconciliation
une réconciliation avec soi-même avec
les autres c'est pour ça que ça
s'appelle je voudrais exister c'est
aussi un livre psychologique sur leurs
collègues cheminement intérieur d'une
personne qui cherche à trouver le chemin
de la liberté
l ouvrage que vous avez vous venez de
sortir voilà ces sorties donc en mars
2018 parfait merci beaucoup
et merci à vous tous deux d'être venu
nous présenter tous ses ouvrages et on
se retrouve on se retrouve très bientôt
au tour de d'une nouvelle série des
ouvrages
je vous remercie d'être d'avoir suivi
cette émission et je vous dis à très
bientôt pour de prochaines découvertes
avec nos invités
merci à vous
[Musique]